oh
non c'est trop triste
bayon j'irai acheter deux kills ou de
cornichons russe non c'est trop
compliqué ça voyons av voilà une très
belle phrase à traduire je suis heureux
quand on commence à se dire d'emblée je
suis heureux je suis heureux i'm happy
i'm happy à bonjour
permettez moi de vous saluer en anglais
hello cela veut dire salut oui je dois
vous avouer que je me suis décidé à
apprendre l'anglais
évidemment avec tous ses nombreux
voyages que je doit entreprendre dans le
monde entier cela est indispensable
salut vous comment on dit je suis
heureux en anglais ils n'ont et bien
cela se dit i'm happy c'est formidable
non ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap adam pas
tant la table bonjour monsieur l'islam
et nous
qu'est-ce qu'a casimir tu as perdu
quelque chose non genre je cherche le
monsieur est éloquent vous venez d'après
marc fait quasiment 7 à toi que je
m'adressais à moi mais oui en fait ils
n'ignorent pas que dans les autres pays
les habitants parlent des langues
différentes de la nôtre oui j'ai entendu
dire que l'on les pays étrangers on
parlait des langues étrangères bonbons
et des moi même je ne t'ai parlé dans
une langue étrangère et l'eau ça veut
dire bonjour en anglais en anglais oui
pas du tout non non non d'abord le arche
doit être aspiré un écu l'accent tonique
et sur la première syllabe écouter et
l'ont
vu comment comment casimir tut tut coach
connaît ce mot en anglais mais
évidemment excusez moi mais j'ai rendez
vous avec mes amis lapin pour faire une
partie de billard ou
trois pêcheurs to meet you good bye bye
bye bye
mais qu'est ce qu'ils racontent il dit
des choses totalement incompréhensible
mais pas du tout mais si le snav casimir
vient de vous dire bon à plus tard
j'étais ravie de vous rencontrer au
revoir mais comment vous parlez le
casimir us bonsoir mais pas du tout
monsieur du snop je ne parle pas le
casimir us je veux traduit ce que
casimir vient de vous dire en anglais en
passant ce grand bal on parle anglais
évidemment si vous n'avez d'ailleurs
kazimierz et les bruits très traduit en
anglais bon évidemment son accent n'est
pas parfait parfait c'est pour cela
et c'est pour ce à quoi ce buzz mais bon
cela que je n'ai pas compris ce qu'il
racontait à cause de son mauvais accent
mais c'est pour ça
j'aperçois mademoiselle futaie qui
approche vous allez pouvoir faire
éclater votre connaissance de la langue
anglaise à parce que mon nom a chuté
aussi des connaissances d'anglais mais
bien sûr monsieur li snob mademoiselle
futé par le plusieurs langues étrangères
c'est mademoiselle futaie est beaucoup
plus à vendre qu'elle en a l'air amusé
merveilleux jeu pouvoir lui dire tout ce
que je ressens mais à seulement il nous
faudra encore quelques minutes pour
réviser quelques minutes sur les accorde
rester la réviser moi je vais la
chercher merci france aux deux
véritables amis je vous en prie lyon 4g
pour lui dire ah bien sûr je fus heureux
à l'api papa
mademoiselle futé jean-françois
i'm happy vient à lima puis
françois simon nous la main
est bien indispensable mais enfin
françois vous savez très bien que j'ai
fait de gros progrès je n'écrase plus
les mêmes personnes oui c'est vrai et
bien allons-y serrons-nous la meuf
oh je suis désolé mais c'est votre four
doux si vous m'avez trouvé avec vos
paroles si vous n'avez rien dit non mais
vous avez fait beaucoup moins mal que la
dernière fois beaucoup plus que la
prochaine bah espérons je suis désolé
françois comment me faire pardonner en
écoutant attentivement
s'agirait-il d'un succès en quelque
sorte oui
monsieur du snob apprend l'anglais et
vous voulez que je lui donne une leçon
on y vient ce sera avec plaisir françois
vous savez combien j'ai de sympathie en
même d'affections telles fuites est
surtout pas le vaisseau avec monsieur
duchesneau vous savez il est très très
susceptibles il le prendrait très mal ne
non surtout pas mais alors que voulez
vous que je fasse c'est très simple
monsieur du snob ne connaît que quelques
phrases en anglais alors il va voulait
sortir très fièrement vous vous allez
l'écouter béatement et surtout lui
répondait rien du tout n'allait pas lui
poser des questions qui pourraient le
mettre dans l'embarras très bien j'ai
compris françois vous pouvez compter sur
moi la noisette fuite à jour merci
beaucoup rester ici je vous envoie me
suis dit stop tout de suite à un
pardon ça fait mal
oui alors voilà je vais lui dire je suis
heureux i'm happy et puis une phrase que
dans ce livre vous êtes belle comme un
bouquet de fleurs à bien
contents mais nous allons futé vous
attend près du qui rend très bien tenus
françois
[Musique]
dallaire de ce passé pour mieux
se passe-t-il en souvenez vous n'avez
pas entendu ce qu'il m'a dit
monsieur du snop s'est trompé de ligne
au lieu de dire à mademoiselle futaie
vous êtes jolie comme un bouquet de
fleurs il lui a dit vous êtes laide
comme une guenon d'afrique pauvre
monsieur du snob ce soit une boîte pu
dire chez lui à une api je suis heureux